[Music]
Hagrid smirked and looked up from the
buffet of firm tight flesh that lays
spread edge before him to tilt his head
questing Lee what the [ __ ] is ready Glee
Dumbledore grinned he has been very good
he said thoughtfully tracing the crease
of harry's hurt ours with a fingertip I
think he deserves both dark Harry
bottled something incoherent with the
frantic movement for a long moment the
older man lost himself in familiar
tastes Oh God then the sound of an
indignant and neglected Harry broke into
their less driven snogging frenzy well
someone just Haggard and Dumbledore
chuckled as Dumbledore picked up as one
releasing Harry's bonds before he cast
lubrication spells Harry gasped then he
yelped when he felt rough hands all him
to his knees and the blood tip of
nudging the entrance to his body
agra shudder to his own release after
Harry sucked him down to the base and
swallowed heard around his everybody he
whimpered as Harry's hand slid between
his legs he oh one key he listed thee
[Music]
yeah
I'm not gonna lie that was weird